I want to announce
that we are going to promote 1 new reform
of the regulations for the development of the law
Alien training
to simplify procedures and improve protection
of migrants' rights.
Our goal is to complete this modification
of the regulations before the first half of the year
of this coming year,
2 024 that is about to begin.
This reform aims to
the transposition of the directives
I have mentioned to you before,
as well as reduce the multiple permit figures
which are now in force
and also the objective of simplifying
documentation and paperwork and to strengthen
protection
of migrants against the former